maybe fauci could explain some of this
to me because he's back baby remember he
took off for like three weeks we didn't
know where he was while we were doing
the war thing well now fauci is back and
he's thinking about locking you down
again
we need to be prepared
for the possibility that we would have
another variant that would come along
and if things change
and we do get a variant that does give
us an uptick in cases and
hospitalization we should be prepared
and flexible enough to pivot
towards going back at least temporarily
to a more rigid type of restriction such
as requiring masks indoor
no
dick
that is the extent of my analysis on
that one uh we've got more video from
fauci is it just a coincidence that
there is a huge coronavirus laboratory
in wuhan well i mean
it is not at all surprising
that there's a research lab in there the
chinese were trying to figure out
and did successfully figure out
what the original ideology was
of saw's kovi one and the very fact that
we did have
a sars cov1
made it very very clear
that there would be a possibility that
we would have another
pandemic outbreak
from the animal human interface
so it makes very good sense
oh
you don't say
you mean the thing that we've all been
saying for two years the thing that rand
paul was going on and on about in that
senate hearing when you got very
indignant you mean the place where
they're researching the stuff and then
the thing leaks out and it's in the city
that the lab's named after and
lordy lordy these people are ridiculous
anyway what's good about all of this of
course is that people just are not
paying attention as much and i don't
think that if they came in and they
decided to lock everybody down yes there
would be a whole slew of people who
would say thank you sir may i have
another and they would gladly go into
their basements and drink all day and
watch porn all day and and whatever like
there's a certain set of people that
would love to just live on the
government dole and that's why the
government wants to break people because
then you're just cogs in the machine and
you'll never you'll never actualize as a
human being that's what that's what a
machine would want you're not an
individual you're just a piece of
something that's it right but enough
people are waking up i think a ton of
people are waking up i think tons of
people no longer believe the lies of
these people i think a ton of people
will not comply if they tried to and i
think there are places once again
florida would be ground zero for this
that simply will not play along and
you know if you live in say california
you live in a very different country
than here in florida and i will throw in
another five dollars into the leave cali
fund
you